the world Athletics Council has today
taken the decisive action to protect the
female category uh in our Sport and to
do so by restricting the participation
of transgender and DSD athletes
the decision was taken in consultation
with a number of stakeholders including
40 member federations
our coaches our athletes and through the
athletes commission as well as a range
of other community groups including
trans groups un experts the
international Olympic Committee and para
Athletics
let me if I may start with the
transgender athletes the majority of
those consulted stated that transgender
athletes should not be competing in the
female category many believe there is
insufficient evidence that trans women
do not retain advantage over biological
women and more more evidence than any
physical advantages have been
ameliorated before they are willing to
consider an option for inclusion into
the female category
unlike DSD athletes there are no
transgender athletes competing in
international competition in athletics
and no observations therefore exist from
the front line in our case the field of
play across the different disciplines
that are specific to our sport I.E
endurance running Sprints throws jumps
and Road events
where the science is insufficient to
justify maintaining testosterone
suppression for transgender athletes the
council agreed it must be guided by our
overarching principle which is to
protect the female category
we cannot in all conscious leave our
transgender regulations as they were at
five nanomoles per liter for at least
one year when we were unsure about the
impact of doing so across all our
disciplines so we need to know more and
we need to know more now
the council has agreed to exclude male
to female transgender athletes who have
been through male puberty from female
world-ranking competitions from March
the 31st at this year
however in order to do further research
in while transgender eligibility
guidelines we will be establishing a
working group whose remit will be to
consult specifically with transgender
athletes to seek views on competing in
athletics to review and maybe commission
additional research where there is
currently limited research and to put
forward recommendations to council
the working group will include an
independent chair up to three council
members two athletes from the athletes
commission a transgender athlete from
Athletics three representatives of Our
member federations and representatives
of the world Athletics health and
science department
let me if I may now turn to our DSD
eligibility
the world's Athletics Council today
decided to reduce the testosterone
threshold for DSD athletes to 2.5
nanomoles per liter across all our
events
we have DSD athletes competing in the
unrestricted events in our Sport and we
have 15 years of data observations and
information directly from our own Sport
and of course our DSD athletes
as far as our medical manager is aware
there is no relevant athlete by that I
mean DSD athlete in jumping or throwing
events among the 13 athletes the medical
manager has been in contact with and
that we mentioned in our consultation
paper all have declined testosterone
suppression or a complete medical
assessment
because of this they have not been
eligible to compete in the restricted
events since 2019.
of those athletes still competing in the
unrestricted events around half are
competing in running events over the
mile and the other half are competing in
distances below 400 meters
we want to give the DSD athlete to our
already competing in our sport I.E in
the unrestricted events all those
outside of 400 to 1 mile the opportunity
to resume competition but our scientific
advice is that six months is the minimum
period necessary to ensure their
naturally high testosterone levels are
no longer giving them an advantage over
biological women
these interim Provisions are only for
athletes who are currently competing in
non-restricted events throwing jumping
running below 400 meters or beyond the
mile the interim Provisions do not apply
to the previously restricted events
the six-month duration chosen for the
interim provision is a compromise to
provide and allow the relevant athletes
who previously competed in unrestricted
events an opportunity to compete in
compliance with our DSD regulations that
were approved today
the six-month period is in line with the
required suppression for the current DSD
regulations and according to the
available science it is enough to bring
hemoglobin levels a key determinant of
performance from natural male levels to
normal female levels it is unlikely to
be sufficient to reduce enough
performance advantage in the power
strength based disciplines therefore we
believe that the interim Provisions are
likely to level the playing field in
running events beyond the mile where 55
of our identified relevant athletes
compete it is likely to still be
insufficient to reduce the unfair
Advantage the relevant athlete
experiences in sprinting events where 45
percent of the identified relevant
athletes are currently competing
DSD athletes who have been competing in
the unrestricted events can apply to
benefit from A reduced six-month period
to maintain testosterone levels under
2.5 nanomoles per liter provided they
apply and suppress their testosterone
level to two Nan at 2.5 nanomoles per
liter before 1 July of this year 2023 so
none of these athletes will be eligible
to compete in the world Athletics
Championships in Budapest in August they
will be eligible to compete in other
events after that six-month period
including the Paris Olympic Games next
year if and only if they maintain their
testosterone at the required level